So let's look at the upsides and
downsides of Direct-Mapped Caches.
When we access the Direct-Mapped Cache,
we need to look in only one place.
That makes this cache fast.
If we need to look in more than one
place, then we need to wait for
all of those to be read out.
We then need to figure out which one
of them, if any need has it and so on.
With the Direct Mapped Cache,
we just check in one place.
If it's there, we have it.
If it's not there, then it's a miss.
So we can very quickly determine
whether we have a hit or not.
So it's very good for hit time.
It is also cheaper than more
complex caches because of it.
We only need to do one comparison
on every access to the cache.
So we only need to have
one type comparator.
One valid bit checker and so on.
And it also makes it energy efficient.
We only need to do one type of
comparison, and one valid bit check
per access, which spends less energy
than if we had to check more than one.
The down sides of this cache
are related to the fact that the block
must go in one place.
To see why this is a problem consider
what happens if the processor
frequently accesses blocks A and
B like this, where both A and
B map to the same place in the cache.
When we access A,
we will bring it to the cache.
When we access B, we need to put it in
the same place where A is currently.
So A needs to be kicked out.
There is no choice about what
we kick out, A has to go out.
When we access A again,
B needs to be kicked out and so on.
So the downside of this cache is
that it can have these conflicts,
where particular blocks
that we want to use.
Fight over the one spot in the cache,
although the cache has plenty of
other spots that are under utilized.
What conflicts do is they
increase the miss rate.
So we can have a cache that
has a fast hit time, but
suffers in the miss rate in return.